- Well y'all know how we
end things around here.
I find something fun and uplifting online,
and I share it with you
this is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering and clapping)
So, so often on this show,
we talk about the chain
reaction of kindness
and that's exactly what
two Michigan teachers
want to prove to their
elementary students.
So they ask the kids
to collect cereal boxes
to donate to the local food bank,
but before they delivered the cereal,
the teachers assembled the boxes
and aligned down multiple
hallways in the school
and with the kids watching,
they demonstrated how
compassion really can
create a domino effect, check this out.
- Three, two, one.
- [Kids] Three, two, one.
(all cheering)
- I love that.
(audience clapping)
I'm like 40 and I find so
much amusement from that.
We have the teachers behind
the cereal domino run
on the line right now.
Let's say hi to Crystal and Angela y'all.
(audience cheering and clapping)
What's up ladies?
Oh my God, love that!
I love that y'all did that.
I'm literally 40 years old
and I like get so much joy from that.
So tell us more about this project though
and how many boxes we're
in your domino chain?
- Yeah, so our mission
here at South Elementary
is joyful learning
and so this is a way that we lived it
and it's just summed up into
those two quick little words.
- Cereal's actually the
number one requested food item
by food banks,
because we can tailor that
more towards what kids want.
Last year, we were able to
raise 711 boxes of cereal
and we thought that was pretty amazing.
This year, we were able to raise
1094 boxes of cereal.
- Oh my gosh!
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Last year I had three students
and this year I had two students
that benefited from the
donated boxes of cereal.
So as teachers, we know
how important this is
and how the need is very, very real.
- It's so cool that
you're teaching them that
at a young age too.
It's so important 'cause when they learn
that kind of kindness and compassion
and empathy at such a young age
it carries out into
their adulthood, right?
So thank y'all for doing that
and also for making it fun
because what did it take
to set up all those boxes?
How long did that take?
- It actually took us about 40 minutes
all hands on deck throughout the district.
We had people running boxes to us,
they were handing boxes off
as we assembled and engineered
the entire run itself.
I was jumping over the boxes,
making Angela really nervous
but I assured her that I had under control
every 10th box or so we removed a box
so that way if 10 of 'em fell
it really wasn't that big of a deal.
- Oh see, that's a teacher move.
That's a teacher move right there.
Yeah 'cause I would not
have thought of that
I was like, oh my God, one
kid, one kid knocks it over
and the whole thing you
have to start over again.
I was like, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- So once all the boxes were lined up,
we had the kids go out in the hall
and we'd tell 'em it was like lava
so they couldn't touch it.
And amazingly with 345 students
in a young five through
second grade classroom,
no boxes were touched,
nothing was knocked over.
(kids cheering)
So it just shows how
responsible they really are.
The run itself took about two minutes
and as you can hear in the video
the kids were just amazed and excited
and it just really shows
what impact that we have
and we're just really excited
to continue to do it in the future.
- I love that.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Well, thank you so much Crystal,
thank you Angela.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(bell rings)
And that's not all.
- [Angela And Crystal] Thank you!
- Oh absolutely that's not all though
our season long partner
Pilot Pin Makers of Friction,
the go to race will pin
of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
just like y'all,
so they're gonna give
Watervliet Public Schools
a thousand dollars.
(all cheering and clapping)
Thank you ladies.